bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver ici au parlement européen pour
cette saison 7 d'europe hebdo et pour
commencer l'année en fanfare la saison
en fanfare c'est en gala merkel et
françois hollande qui ont décidé
vingt-cinq ans après helmut kohl et
françois mitterrand lors de la
réunification allemande de venir
s'adresser ici aux parlementaires
européens et comme on peut s'en douter
c'est la crise migratoire la crise des
réfugiés qui a occupé une bonne partie
de leurs discours alors avant de
retrouver mes invités pour décrypter et
analyser
petit florilège
nous avons répondu par l'affirmation de
principes 5 est clair la solidarité la
responsabilité
et la fermeté
l'europe n'a pas mesuré l'espoir qu'elle
suscite et quelques sujets draps
longtemps face au au désarroi de ceux
qui attendent depuis
la nuit qui c'est pour eux
ouverte depuis trop longtemps
attendent l'espoir la lumière l'europe
n'a pas prodigué avec suffisamment
d'ampleur l'aide à des pays qui pourtant
accueillies dans des camps des
populations toujours plus nombreuses
alors c'est donc dans l'urgence que la
dû s'organiser l'europe pour être digne
de sa tradition d'acide et pour
organiser le retour de ceux de celles
qui ne peuvent pas être accueillis ici
durablement le contrôle effectif des
frontières extérieures de l'union passe
par une assistance renforcée aux états
frontières aux états concernés et par la
mise en place d'accords de
gardes-frontière de garde-côtes
européens comme le président de la
commission européenne en a fait la
proposition
de même nous devons définir une
politique d'asile plus cohérente ce qui
passe par une liste commune de pays
d'origine sur le rapprochement des
procédures la convergence des droits et
des conditions offertes aux
bénéficiaires d'une protection c'est à
dire un véritable régime commun d'asile
au sein même de l'union européenne
nous nous devons assumer de façon
responsable l'attrait de l'europe cela
signifie également que nous devons nous
préoccuper davantage des personnes dans
le besoin à nos frontières et si nous
estimons que ce défi un défi commun à
nous tous c'est alors que
nous reconnaîtrons la chance qu'offre
pour nous c'était progressé alors que
nous constaterons que ses chances sont
beaucoup plus importantes que les
risques
voilà donc françois hollande et en gala
merkel ont occupé une bonne partie de
l'après midi ce mercredi au parlement
européen
et pour en discuter pour analyser et
décrypter en fait ces discours se
guillaume balas que je reçois bonjour
vous êtes député européen français
membre du groupe socialiste on vous
connaît pour être plutôt à l'ailé gauche
ce qu'on dirait les frondeurs en
français ça me voilà tout à fait andré à
cheval merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député européen allemand et vous êtes
membre du groupe ppe donc le parti
d'angela merkel merci d'être avec nous
je vais vous poser la question tout beau
est ce que vous considérez que ce
discours était important qu'il était
novateur on a appris et on sait que
c'était quelque chose d'inédit depuis
1989 est ce que vous êtes déçu par les
annonces guillon de balès je pense que
c'était nécessaire ils viennent c'est
est nécessaire qu'ils parlent c'était
nécessaire notamment qu'il ya un certain
nombre d' annonce qui était qu'ils
soient faites sur la zone euro
simplement quand même il ya des choses
qui qui avance c'était nécessaire qui
rappellent pourquoi il y avait eu cette
attitude commune sur la question des
réfugiés qui est absolument essentiel
aux valeurs européennes est-ce que
c'était suffisant non bien évidemment ça
ne l'était pas et maintenant le travail
commence pour faire ce qui a été donné
comme feu l'autre si on dit qu'il faut
maintenant approfondir renforcer
démocratiser en plus puissante l'europe
il va maintenant falloir décrypter les
outils pour le faire et c'est ça qu'on
attend et notamment le parlement
européen je crois et les le groupe
socialiste en particulier va être très
attentif sur comment on fait de la
démocratie de la politique sociale de la
convergence écologique en europe
maintenant est de votre côté en dh la
baisse que vous êtes déçu est ce que
vous avez considéré qu'il n'avait pas
été assez loin dans leurs discours n'ont
mangé le temps moi je suis un peu plus
modeste mais je pense que c'est vrai que
les grandes annonces n'ont pas été
faites mais c'est difficile et je pense
que si on a suivi le débat il est vrai
que si la france et l'allemagne viennent
ensemble avec des recettes commune ils
sont critiqués quand ils n'ont pas de
recettes de projets concrets ils sont
traités qui est aussi donc le processus
est long et donc il faut être aussi un
peu moins on est dans le symbole là
finalement est ce qu'on n'est pas dans
juste de la stricte communication il
fallait montrer un couple franco franco
allemand leader en europe c'est quoi
l'idée d'un chip leader
je vais pas si c'est pour montrer
diverses et pour montrer en tout cas que
le tandem existe je crois que c'est
vraiment existé tout quoi existe encore
je crois que c'est important parce que
nous avons aujourd'hui des divergences
profondes sur certains sujets potentiels
sur la question économique sur la
questions géostratégiques et nous voyons
que nous sommes capables de les de les
passer de les dépasser sur certains
sujets je pense à l'ukraine où les
positions de départ était quand même
très éloigné nous avons réussi à
construire ensemble maintenant tout est
à faire notamment sur la question
économique et sur la question de la
convergence économique de
l'harmonisation sociale on voit bien là
il ya des différences qui sont très
importantes il va falloir s'y atteler
mais alors là le problème si je dois
reprendre votre idée de convergence
c'est que ne serait-ce qu entre
l'allemagne et la france il ya des idées
de convergence sur lesquels on n'est pas
d'accord et a fortiori à 28 ça va être
encore plus compliqué on aurait un choix
parce que vous êtes d'accord avec l'idée
qu'il faut avoir plus d'intégration
européenne au niveau de la zone euro
comme ça a été énoncée par françois
hollande je pense que tout le monde qui
suit les affaires européennes est
conscient du fait qu'il faut plus
d'intégration européenne non seulement
dans des questions de la coopération
économique mais ceci étant dit c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de l'emploi de
le réaliser et donc c'est vrai que c'est
un peu dommage qu'on n'a pas eu de
promesse ou de grands projets
aujourd'hui mais le message commun
d'angela merkel et de françois hollande
aujourd'hui c'était quand même un
message clair et si on regarde la
plénière du parlement européen ça peut
nous faire un peu mal comment une grande
partie de cette chambre 2 7 de ce
parlement n'est plus sur la même ligne
dont dans ce qui concerne l'intégration
européenne qui nous a menés dans une
situation où le bien-être même si on
regarde les problèmes qui a est le plus
élevé que nous avons jamais vécu en
europe alors il ya un gros dossier qui a
occupé 80% si je puis dire des discours
c'est la question des réfugiés avant de
revenir sur les annonces je voudrais
qu'on reprenne un petit peu le fil pour
nos spectateurs de cette crise des
réfugiés qui s'est réveillé et qui nous
a un petit peu interpellé et pris un peu
au dépourvu en plein été on écoute
c'est au creux de l'été que l'ampleur de
la crise a surpris les dirigeants
européens cent cinquante six mille
migrants pénètrent sur le territoire
pour le seul mois d'août les centres
d'accueil déborde les camps de réfugiés
fleuriste aux frontières dans les villes
dans les campagnes les médias
s'emballent
depuis le 1er janvier 2015 plus de cinq
cent mille hommes femmes et enfants
entrent en europe l'année dernière il
était à peine 300 milles
l'allemagne ouvre grand ses portes
tandis que la majeure partie des pays
d'europe cherche à juguler les flux et
repoussé ces réfugiés venus pour la
plupart de syrie d'irak d'erythrée près
de 3000 personnes trouvent la mort dans
la traversée de la méditerranée pourtant
mi septembre c'est la photo d'un enfant
syrien et l'âne qui émeut tout le
continent
branle bas de combat les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement s'empare du dossier à la
clé 160 mille réfugiés seront répartis
équitablement dans les pays européens
des centres d'identification appelé hot
spots seront installés en italie en
grèce pour gérer ces réfugiés seule la
hongrie persiste et refuse sept cent
mille réfugiés devraient rejoindre
l'europe en 2015 selon le hcr de quoi
s'attendre à une nouvelle crise
politique entre les 28 dans les semaines
à venir
andré h fab quand on voit à quel point
il a été difficile pour l'europe et
hollande et françois hollande le disait
dans son discours l'europe n'a pas été
capable de gérer cette crise à la du
retard à l'allumage est-ce que
globalement l'europe n'est pas dans
l'incapacité de gérer toutes les crises
non je ne pense pas du tout c'est vrai
qu'il faut améliorer le système le
système de câble inc le système de
schengen il faut faire plus beaucoup
plus mais le problème avec lequel nous
voyons confrontés c'est que les
développements se font beaucoup plus
rapide et au niveau européen il faut que
nous réagissions plus rapide que dans le
passé mais à 28 et s'est pas laissée en
capacité de le faire à 28 on a vu qu'il
était à quel point il était difficile de
se départager 160 mille réfugiés alors
qu'elle a déjà quasi 500000 sont
intéressés des réfugiés qui sont étaient
déjà arrivés il y a d'autres qui sont
donc en train de devenir 700 millions on
est en 2e on a le besoin d'être plus
rapide à haut niveau des 28 ça c'est un
vrai enjeu et ça prendra quelque temps
pour s'adapter et c'est ça l'enjeu
actuel est ce que vous êtes d'accord
guillaume balas et aujourd'hui il ya eu
quelque chose d'important de 10000 faut
aller très très vite c'est la remise en
cause de dublin alors pour être clair la
convention de dublin c'est une
convention qui fait en sorte que chaque
pays qui reçoit en premier lieu les
réfugiés où les migrants se débrouille
et les prennent en charge ils veulent
comme ferment un mécanisme solide c'est
l'inversé même de l'esprit européen il
faut mettre à bas la convention dublin
effet roettgen d'accord avec elle donc
de ce point de vue oui oui
sur le second point c'est évidemment la
question de schengen ne s'agit pas comme
le demande nicolas sarkozy de revenir
des politiques nationales mis 14 c'est
ça son idée de schengen non c'est au
contraire de renforcer schengen pour
aller vers une politique migratoire
commune est ce que c'est possible mais
là de la même manière un noyau peut
démarrer aujourd'hui sur cette question
est d'ailleurs le couple franco-allemand
de ce point de vue a plutôt bien
fonctionné bon ensuite entraîné les
autres je voudrais vous faire remarquer
quand même que il a eu un vote à la
majorité qualifiée sur la répartition
des migrants ou quand il a fallu prendre
des décisions on a su quand même le
faire j'aimerais que sur beaucoup de
sujets ouais on soit capable de faire la
même chose williams et notamment la
question géopolitique et ce qui se passe
en ciel sur le vote à majorité qualifiée
effectivement il a fallu en passer par
d'habitude ça passe plutôt par lunel
mais là il a fallu passer par parrot
pour pouvoir obtenir le fait de se
répartir 168 personnes mais là moi je
leur pose la question cent soixante
mille personnes qu'on a réussi après
deux conseil justice et affaires
intérieures un sommet européen se
répartir alors qu'ils sont déjà 500
milles sur le territoire et 700000
certainement à la fin de l'année 2015 on
va pas retomber encore dans une crise
dans quelques mois prendre et à cheval
non j'espère que l'on mais c'est
clairement difficile de convaincre les
28 d'une politique commune que une
politique qu'on a encore refusé à la fin
de l'année dernière on change très
rapidement
d'une position à l'autre bien que au
niveau européen il était déjà clair qu'à
un certain moment du bling 3 et n'était
plus tenable la plupart des pays membres
voulaient qu'on ne touche pas car
c'était un compromis et on voulait
garder ce qu'on a déjà assez de
difficultés à trouver ce compromis la
halle après l'autre question c'est les
pays qui ne veulent pas de cette
solidarité on pense notamment à viktor
orban qui est de votre cambrai jeux
fabriqués au ppe donc c'est le premier
ministre hongrois qui a mis en place une
frontière avec des fils barbelés qui a
mis en place aussi un arsenal juridique
qui permet aujourd'hui aux policiers aux
forces de l'ordre ont droit de tirer sur
les migrants à balles non létales certes
mais de tirer sur les mines on n'aura en
allemagne et l'expulser laura je vais
vous dire en allemagne on a une grande
coalition souvent c'est pour ça qu'on
est plus analytique dans le dans le
groupe socialiste il ya des premiers
ministres qui ont dit n'importe quoi et
ça existe un peu partout donc il faut
trouver des solutions à des problèmes et
des vraies solutions on a vu en hongrie
que depuis la création des murs ne
fonctionnera pas parler fut réfugiés
viennent encore et je pense c'est un
c'est une réflexion qu'on peut rendre
majoritaire mais il faut trouver des
solutions aussi des solutions pour des
pays comme la grèce avec les frontières
extrêmement large des solutions pour des
pays comme la croatie ou dpi sur le
balcon des solutions pour l'on grille
mais aussi pour les réfugiés qui sont
arrivés en allemagne alors tout à la
fois assez difficile vous ne faites
justement une transition rêver parce
qu'on n'a été figurez-vous en sicile qui
est un des premiers pays à recevoir donc
des migrants qui arrivent par la
méditerranée et eux ont beaucoup de mal
à gérer cette situation c'est un
reportage de gaël goujon
m
8 heures c'est le début d'une journée
ordinaire pour la sicile
280 migrants débarqués au port de
messine à bord de ce bateau affrété par
l'agencé européenne frontex des syriens
les soudanais les erythréens ils ont été
sauvés après 12 jours d'errance en
méditerranée leur traversée a débuté sur
les côtes égyptiennes en moyenne elle a
coûté 2000 euros par personne
amer professeur de philosophie a fui
damas en syrie avec sa femme et ses deux
enfants de 7 et 10 ans leur premier
objectif se laver après des semaines de
voyage
on va manger se reposer pendant un ou
deux jours et fut ensuite on va
continuer notre chemin car pour amer la
sicile n'est qu'une étape dans cette
longue transhumance sa destination malmö
en suède sur les 90 mille réfugiés qui a
accosté en sicile 85% en partie
immédiatement pour continuer leur voyage
plus au nord
avant d'obtenir des papiers ces migrants
patientent souvent des mois dans des
centres d'accueil
mineo le plus grand centre d'hébergement
d'europe est une ancienne base de l'otan
il prend en charge plus de 3000
personnes sur les douze mille réfugiés
restent est actuellement en sicile
devant le centre nous avons rencontré un
jeune manière de 26 ans il a préféré
rester alors à ce moment il y attendait
les taxi pour aller à catania pour faire
court on a récupéré mais permet dès 16
heures comme beaucoup de migros sa
demande de récépissé est refusé pour
l'union européenne le mali est un pays
sûr il risque l'expulsion
d'après ken être adressées mais
ni si c'est encore pire
sur la zf et les prisons en libye après
je voulais retourner dans dix ans pour
redresser la barre cela va même
jusqu'à
d'espoir parce que en moins il est
vivant quand même
les mineurs eux sont mieux prises en
charge la loi italienne impose un tuteur
chargé de les accompagner dans leurs
démarches camara modibo 17 ans vient
d'effectuer seul un dangereux périple
depuis la gambie ils m'ont attrapé il me
fracasser les doigts c'est cette
histoire là qu'il va falloir raconté à
la commission
carla trop milo est avocate à syracuse
et oriente les jeunes migrants
le nombre d'éloignements ou plutôt de
jeunes qui disparaissent dans la nature
car il s'agit bien de ça c'est
drastiquement écroulé depuis qu'on mène
notre activité
à floridia près de syracuse le maire de
centre gauche a dû lutter contre ses
administrés pour héberger sur sa commune
un centre d'accueil il faut des
politiques de gestion intelligente et ça
ne peut pas être seulement à l'italie de
gérer ce phénomène mais l'île reste la
première région d'accueil ghitany ce qui
crée des tensions
ces migrants sont vus comme des rivaux
car la population pense que l'état
s'occupe d'eux et ne fait rien pour les
italiens
même si en fait ce n'est pas vrai et il
s'agit de budgets différents
démunis ces migrants sont aujourd'hui
une proie facile beaucoup exploite cette
misère
on va essayé d'interroger des
travailleurs agricoles il devrait être
en pause déjeuner
excuse-moi voulais te demander bon
celui-là déjà eu film
ce sont des demandeurs d'asile hébergés
dans notre pays en fait ils sont obligés
de travailler dans des conditions quasi
d'esclavagé
une main d'oeuvre à bas coût une aubaine
pour les propriétaires terriens
quand je vais au travail certains me
paye mais d'autres noms alors que tu
travailles il te paye 20 euros pour 12
heures voire 14 ou même 18 heures
tout ça parce qu'on n'a pas encore tous
nos papiers
des papiers ultime graal après des mois
voire des années de voyage à la merci
des tortionnaires des passeurs puis
d'exploitants sans scrupules en 2015 les
nations unies tablent sur près de 700000
arrivée sur le territoire européen un
chiffre qui ne fera qu augmenter dans
les années à venir
guillaume balas quand on voit la
situation en sicile quand on voit à quel
point il est difficile en fait pour un
pour une petite petite île comme celle
ci de prendre en charge quasi 90000
personnes qui sont arrivées sur son
territoire est-ce qu'on n'est pas là
aussi en manque de solidarité par
rapport à ces pays qui sont un premier
front des trains une évidence et moi je
veux remercier toujours le peuple
italien de rester profondément européen
avec l'abandon dans lequel il a été face
à cette crise je trouve ça assez
extraordinaire et donc je remercie
vraiment les italiens du sud de cette
solidarité mental avec nous qui n'avons
pas été solidaire à ceux à ce moment là
mais je voudrais revenir quand même sur
un point qui peut paraître anecdotique
mais à mon avis qu'il n'est pas oui il y
a dans nos partis aujourd'hui des gens
qui disent des choses qui sont
condamnables monsieur fiscaux qui est
chancelier social-démocrate aujourd'hui
de la slovaquie a dit des choses qui
sont inadmissibles moi je pense qu'il
doit partir de la famille social
démocrate je pense que monsieur ban doit
aussi partir du ppe il faut que les
choses soient claires parce que
autrement tout est brouillée évidemment
ça ne répond pas à la question que vous
posez mais quand même clarifier nos
positions politiques c'est important par
rapport par rapport à ce sujet
maintenant la réponse de fond à tout
cela c'est évidemment plus d'intégration
et d'instruments européens ce qui veut
dire que notamment il faut construire
des gardes frontières européens il faut
une rue l'égard de colère sans dire que
je n'en suis hollande appelle de ses
voeux absolument il faut une politique
d'intégration européenne et donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut une politique migratoire
commune et discuter très vite des
critères d'admission parce que on
s'arrêtera pas sans péril commun aux
politiques migratoires je veux partir
j'aime bien ma voix de politique
migratoire je ne crois pas le la
l'immigration zéro est une absurdité
qu'on a vendu en france et qui nous mène
aujourd'hui dans la situation de folie
psychologique dans laquelle on est par
rapport à l'immigration il faut admettre
et parfois même souhaité de dire que
l'immigration peut être une excellente
chose à partir du moment où elle est
préparée ou les gens qu'on a qu'elles le
sont dans des voies là que ce soit
convenable et que l'on puisse faire en
sorte que ces gens veuillent être
français et je crois que c'est possible
dans les autres pays européens et que
l'europe pourrait être une aide pour
nous car ils ont su faire parfois des
choses que nous ne savons plus faire
dans notre poche justement dans la
sphère en voit que angela merkel a
quelques difficultés à imposer le fait
que vous ayez reçu énormément de
réfugiés depuis quelques mois c'est
globalement l'allemagne et la suède qui
prennent en charge le plus de réfugiés
en europe peggy d'acquis et le parti
d'extrême droite a réussi aussi à
remobiliser depuis septembre cette
question de l'intégration elle est
importante pour les allemands comment
est ce que vous allez pouvoir prendre en
charge alors d'abord permettez-moi de
revenir peut-être rapidement je trouve
d'abord maintenant il faut parler une
politique commune en ce qui concerne les
conditions et la répartition des des
demandeurs d'asile car si ils viennent
on peut pas les refuser et donc la
migration ça sera un sujet pour après je
pense personnellement car d'abord il ya
les gens qui viennent dé la série des
guerres qui veulent juste chercher le
bien-être et la paix et pas plus donc
une politique commune pour les
conditions
des chercheurs des demandeurs d'asile
est en plus une meilleure protection des
frontières et en plus une meilleure un
meilleur soutien pour le chant de
réfugiés aussi des idées comme on peut
arrêter la guerre en syrie
avec ceci dit je pense qu'il faut c'est
ce que nous avons aussi fait dans notre
groupe un débat clair aussi au sein de
nos partis c'est pas facile car il ya
des des pays qui ont peu de migrants qui
ont peu de cherche des demandeurs
d'asile pour eux c'est plus difficile de
s'adapter à ce débat d'autres ont du mal
à penser au coût de ces demandeurs
d'asile donc il faut faire un débat et
je pense du débat ne doit pas ce que la
thur et se clôturer d'ici la fin de
l'année on peut se permettre un peu plus
de temps mais ce dont on a besoin d'elle
de but c'est de la solidarité que
l'europe peut gagner cette
victoire dans une telle situation
seulement ensemble même si quelques pays
prennent un peu de retard et d'autres
montrent un peu en avance alors là on a
bien vu que la question des hotspots ces
centres d'identification et est
clairement posée on voit aussi qu'on
demande beaucoup à la turquie qui va
falloir aider et puis derrière à l'union
africaine qu'il va falloir que le renvoi
certainement nos migrants économiques
globalement est ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de rejeter la responsabilité de ce
flux de réfugiés à des gens qui sont
extérieurs à l'europe que son il faut
quand même se rendre compte d'une chose
c'est que cette crise des réfugiés à mon
avis n'est pas séparable de la question
migratoire de manière globale nous
sommes face à des secteurs aujourd'hui
géographie qui sont en pleine transition
démographique qui ont énormément de
populations jeunes sacré des gars ça
crée des tensions ça crée du désordre
mais ça crée aussi de la migration
économique séparer les deux de manière
absolue et et à mon avis illusoire donc
il va falloir qu'on se prépare à cela et
donc il va falloir dialoguer avec eux
pour voir comment on crée les meilleures
infrastructures chez eux pour essayer
justement de faire en sorte que ces
migrations soient les moins compliqué
possible voire qu'elle n'ait pas lieu
quand elles peuvent ne pas avoir lieu je
crois que c'est cette réflexion
géopolitique que nous devons avoir mais
pour cela vraiment il ya quelque chose
de très important il faut que l'europe
se met à faire de la politique et de
soin de lui j'ai un petit regret madame
merkel a paru faire de la politique sur
un point c'est la défense de volkswagen
tout à l'heure en disant faut faire
attention pour l'industrie automobile et
souvent en france on ne parle aussi que
d'économie le problème de l'europe
principal aujourd'hui c'est ce que nous
sommes capables de créer une union
politique sur la question de l'armé de
la défense sur la question migratoire
sur la question de l'aide au
développement et c'est là dessus qu'on
pourra construire je vais dire quelque
chose d'efficace ou pour nos citoyens
ils pourront se dire que l'europe sert à
quelque chose autrement très sincèrement
il avoir un déficit de légitimité qui
fera gagner ceux qui aujourd'hui veulent
détruire ce que nous essayons de
construire est ce que vous êtes d'accord
on à l'achat parce qu'il faut aller
encore plus loin et faire une europe
politique là où on n'a créé que de
l'économie jusque là alors je pense le
point sur les automobiles est arrivé à
travers les verts c'est vrai que madame
merkel a répondu mais c'est pas le
l'enjeu principal aujourd'hui l'enjeu
principal c'est comment faire en sorte
que l'europe qui est divisée sur
quelques questions / nature par histoire
par tradition et de mettre ensemble les
28 états membres dans une situation de
pression nous sommes sous pression et on
peut maintenant débattre comment on
arrive à maîtriser tout ça mais il est
clair à la fin ça sera seulement
possible ensemble et je pense qu on a
bien vu aujourd'hui parlement qu'il y a
de force importante qui ne veulent pas
c'est un ensemble en europe et ça nous
fait peur et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
essayer de trouver une solution commune
ce sera le mot de la fin donc merci
monsieur d'avoir participé et analyser
avec nous à chausser discours d'angela
merkel et françois hollande c'est fini
pour nous pour cette semaine la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez ahmed tazir et
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires ciao